okay talk about coin flipping let's say
you've got two people you got person a
person B like the flipping coins let's
say one of them is flipping coins and
waiting for heads heads to turn up right
so that they're going to make a sequence
of coin flips and they're waiting for
head heads person B he's doing it and
he's waiting for head tails so one of
them is waiting for head heads and one
of them is written for head tails now
what's the probability that you're going
to get heads heads I mean amber even
Brady would probably know this what's
the probability you get heads heads
is it 104 yeah yeah exactly so it's one
in four and it's tailed it's the same
right it's one in four even though they
have equal probability I claim your
average waiting time for heads heads is
going to be longer than four head tails
let's do it I mean let's do the
experiment that's not just write out
mathematical formula let's let's do it
let's up okay I'm going to flip this
coin now this is we're going to an
average I want to do a long sequence I
mean we're going to see what the average
is so if I flip this coin let's say 50
times there's a nice long number then
we'll be able to take an average of how
long we have to wait for heads heads or
heads tails right so we do this if it
actually this is going to take me ages
isn't it so instead of flipping this one
coin 50 times what I can do is I can
flip 50 coins all at once so which I've
just done there okay the first coin is a
tails all right second coin is without
looking it's a heads all right next coin
is tails I'm going to do a sequence like
er not even looking we've run out of
space we'd better do another let's make
them random right so I poured them out I
tried not to look at them so it should
be a sequence of random coin flips there
are better write out so we can see what
they are a bit better tail head tail
head tail and a head and a tail and a
tail tail head tail alright we're going
to look at this sequence and we're going
to play the game we're tossing a
sequence of coins and we're waiting to
see how many a Halloween
wait forehead tail if I start here I'm
looking for a head tail Oh Bev tits
right all right that's my first head
tail there that was a waiting time of
three and then I got head tail and then
I start again okay I do a new game
I'm gonna look for head tail and I had
to wait one two three four there it is
now we're doing it oh look this one is
straight away look head tail now I'm
going to start again
I'm looking for head - all this is a
long wait here and then there it is head
tail and Oh head tail there there it is
oh there's one right at the ends well
right what was the average waiting time
let's have a look at the waiting time
it's about an average weight of 4.5
let's look at the heads heads though you
would have to wait how long well this is
a long waiting time here it happens all
the way over here their heads heads
which was a long wait one two three four
five six seven eight nine 10 11 12 13 14
so you've played a game and it ends when
you get heads heads
great done so now we start a new game
completely different game from this
point on so we'll just start again oh
but this time notice there the head
heads comes up really quickly look at
that it's so straight away it up - and
now we start a new game okay so we had a
success we'll start a new game and we
have to wait one two three let's look
for our average waiting time for heads
heads okay which is seven right and yes
oh look yes you have a longer average
waiting time for heads heads
then you do for heads tails even though
there they have an equal probability for
both 1/4 why is this you can kind of see
what that reason is from this this
sequence because if you noticed when we
were doing it when you play heads tails
no you get heads tails then you start a
new game and you wait hota tails and you
start a new game heads heads was
slightly different when we did it with
heads heads look what happened here when
you have something like this heads heads
heads heads we have this overlap and
this overlap isn't counted we were
playing it until we got heads heads
in the game stopped and then we play a
new game from that point so here we've
got our heads heads that didn't get
counted as a heads head so if you look
at how many heads heads we've got it
should be about an equal number two
heads tails but the overlaps don't get
counted mean let's just check so how
many heads tails did we have actually no
we got eleven I know for a fact we've
got eleven how many heads heads did we
have including the overlaps one here we
have two we have three so if you get to
count up the heads heads we had nine of
them but only six were included in our
waiting time average to this sequence we
were looking at what would happen four
consecutive values so you know head
heads heads tails the same sort of thing
would happen with tails heads and tails
tails we're looking at consecutive
values in fact the reason I mentioned
this is because if you remember there
was that prime news where they were
looking at primes and their ending of
primes four consecutive Prime's this is
what they were looking for they thought
all if Prime's are random like coin
flips I'm going to find this effect what
turned out to be the case is that they
don't find this effect because the
Prime's weren't being random like coins
if you did this forever you had a
sequence out just get went on to
infinity and the average waiting time
then is I'll show you what that is
it's called expectation or expected
waiting time the expected rate in time
for head tails is equal to 4 which kind
of makes sense when it's a quarter
probability that that does make sense
and then the expected waiting time for
heads heads is longer and it's 6 so we
were we were close birds as a little bit
off and if you wanted to the expected
waiting time for tails tails
well that's six as well as the same idea
baubles ever-growing collection of books
and other spoken material has now
reached in the order of 250,000 titles
so no matter what you're interested in
audible is bound to have multiple
options for you now I spend a lot of
time driving as you can see here often
in the UK's delightful traffic and there
are few better ways to pass the time
than listening to audiobooks you can
have something entertaining something
educational or maybe a bit of both the
choice is yours
I particularly enjoy books about
mountaineering these titles here about
Mount Everest all very good I put their
details in the description along with
this one about k2 which is one of my
favorites as well and that's just a
fraction of the mountaineering books on
audible I told you they've got something
for everyone if you'd like to give them
a try go to audible.com slash
numberphile and you can sign on for
their free 30-day trial that trial
includes your first book and as I said
there are plenty to choose from that
address again audible.com slash
numberphile so they'll know you came
from our channel which is handy for us
and then the free trial for 30 days
our thanks to audible for supporting
this episode of numberphile maths works
if maths just works it's wonderful that
way how Nats just works out every time
every time just how you want it to work
out especially with the power of editing
were what happened we did our first take
and we got the opposite result from what
we wanted Danya 48 over 11 which is the
opposite of what I said and we have to
film the whole thing again
right